thirty years ago the objects declared
war over watch was created to rescue
humanity from the uptick crisis we
became the greatest champions of peace
and progress mankind has ever seen
[Music]
everybody knows overwatch got shut down
half of our merges mercenaries now
people decided they were better off
fulfilled us thank you for calling us
cradles they tore our family apart Papa
told me after so many years of service
you gave overwatch everything and then
they boost you ours
real life is not like the stories our
father told us your iPhone for believing
it phone perhaps I am a fool to think
there is still hope for you brother
human
[Music]
before me I see the future humans and
only standing together
the second dominant crisis continues the
conflict between our mix and humans has
now claimed over 15,000 lives would you
do that
someone has to do something
custard - something always remember
never accept the world as it appears to
be dare to see it from what it could be
it's been too long what is this this is
protesting on the overwatch emergency
frequency
I'm getting the band back together they
want me but really
they need you
I must answer all the ways the enemy is
out there
getting stronger
the world is changing once again and
to pick a side we can make a difference
again
the world needs us now more than ever
are you with me yes wiesen I am with you
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Game Director of
overwatch Geoff Kaplan
[Applause]
I'll do it you have fun Blizzcon is so
edgy this year I wore black it's kind of
like dad edgy because it's got a giant
pink bunny on it so I didn't quite get
there so I feel like you and I and you
know who I'm talking to you I feel like
you and I have been together for a very
long time like we remember when Wow
classic used to be called Wow it's been
up we've been around together
I have something don't ever say that I
have something that I'm very embarrassed
to tell you now and I'm only telling you
because we have this close relationship
I totally forget what I'm supposed to
say right now like I don't have a clue
just drew a blank anybody who knows me
knows I can just ramble for it forever
about anything but I like luckily I can
from the internet I can read everything
I'm supposed to say from the last week
thank you so much for helping me with
that oh my gosh that was so sweet the
team really appreciate actually if you
want to know how game developers feel
about leaks the WoW team made a
cinematic called Shadowlands and picture
my face where Silvana says was and then
instead of that helmet it was my cell
phone and that's yeah I should probably
talk about overwatch I'm just digging a
hole you know so a very dear friend of
mine
five years ago on on this stage almost
to this very day a gentleman by the name
of Chris Metzen and let him hear it he's
watching with us right now
Chris came out five years ago on this
stage and he said it's time for a new
adventure and he wanted to take us all
with him
and he came out and he announced over
watching it was one of the most special
moments of my life and the women and men
who work on overwatch had been working
so hard to make something very special
and today they'd like to dedicate that
to you so please enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
wisdom
what's on your mind may do do we have
enough people for this mission as long
as we stick together we'll be fine if
you go into Shaw now would be a good
time attention this is your captain
speaking we are on final approach to
Paris
that's what you you may now know all
your electronic devices where there is
mostly cloudy with 100% chances null
sector invasion
[Music]
Winston clear is a spot to land we'll be
right behind you
you better be
- all sector exactly now
but the people down there
right now
we're all we've got
[Music]
Bonjour officer we're here to help
[Music]
city our son
good work man
turn corner
[Music]
[Music]
she needs help we can't stay here
tracer get everyone out of here
I'll hold the line but you're set to
stick together
don't worry I'll be right behind you
you'd better be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
huge
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you [ __ ] die
[Music]
interlock shield
[Music]
many we did
[Music]
victory is ours my friends hi Lena
Brigitta oh my gosh you've grown Oh
everyone this is me hi everyone I still
meet you
Monsieur does this mean overwatch is
back
[Music]
yes yes we are
[Music]
did you like it did you enjoy awesome on
behalf of the overwatch team I am
extremely proud and excited to finally
and officially announce overwatch to now
I know you have a lot of questions but
we always feel like our games speak for
themselves so let's take a look at the
gameplay and then we'll talk
[Applause]
as long as I can what are you doing here
it's happening again
Paris was just the beginning this is a
global emission
the killer robot
you're with me we're getting aboard that
ship
you you would return one day it has been
too long
do this
made your choice
nobody has stopped us
[Music]
trouble is cropping up all over the
world it's not just about center
lot of lives are riding on what we do
next
have to fight one city at a time
[Music]
Perdita
watching your back
a new trick
[Music]
wasn't
to push it brings
[Music]
sojourn here
oh we are gonna have so much fun it is
gonna be so awesome so we have a lot to
talk about right first and foremost you
have to remember that overwatch is a
team versus team 6v6 competitive
experience and there is no way we're
losing that at all in fact that's a huge
focus so overwatch - we'll have a brand
new core competitive game mode called
push now what I mean when I say core is
that you will play this in quick play it
will be played and competitive and it
will also be played by the overwatch
League so we're really excited to
finally add a new core game-mode now we
want everybody here today to have a
chance to play it and tell us how
awesome and balanced it is so you can
play on a brand new map which takes
place in Toronto our first Canadian map
[Music]
it's over in Hall a so we invite you to
come play the demo we think you ought to
be awesome now when I talked to lots of
you there's a common request that you
want out of overwatch and overwatch - is
going to deliver on this and that's for
more story and for PvE for cooperative
experiences overwatch - will feature a
ton of PvE content we will have a
complete story experience featuring
story missions the first of which which
is called Rio de Janeiro is also
playable in Hall a for all of you today
cannot wait to hear what you think about
it in addition as you saw we have
something called hero missions which
hero missions are focused on highly
replayable cooperative experience
the analogy we like to use on the team
is similar to what Adventure mode is to
Diablo versus its campaign that's what
hero missions are intended to be and
they're powered by this really cool
progression system where you can level
up your heroes get more power
full customized your abilities do
different talents it's going to be a ton
of fun now you might have also noticed
the hero's all have a new look to them
every one of the 31 heroes plus more are
getting an upgraded look to them and
there's a really awesome panel that's
going to happen tomorrow on Saturday in
here that is going to go through all of
the engine upgrades that are coming to
overwatch - and all of the new looks and
explanation of the new art style that
I'm really excited about now overwatch
and overwatch - at their core are all
about heroes and we know that we cannot
make a brand new overwatch game without
having new heroes so overwatch - in
addition to featuring sojourn who we are
not talking about today besides just
confirming that she is here
overwatch - will feature multiple new
heroes that will come with the game and
we're very excited about that
now a lot of you have questions like why
a sequel or what does that mean to me as
a player of the original game I put so
much time into this game I cared about
it so much well we thought about it and
for us as gamers you know sequels make
us nervous more than anything else so
what we're hoping to do with overwatch -
is really redefine what a sequel means
and I think some explanation is in order
right now so for all original players of
overwatch players of the current
overwatch game you will get to play on
all of the same maps as overwatch -
players including all of the brand-new
maps that are coming to overwatch - and
you will get to play with all of the
same heroes as overwatch tube players it
will be a shared multiplayer environment
where no one gets left behind
the other thing that I think a lot of us
are thinking about is all those cool
accomplishments and cosmetics that we've
been unlocking over the years you know
how hard did you work for your witch
mercy skin for example we want to make
sure that all overwatch cosmetics come
forward with you into overwatch too so
all of your progress matters nothing's
getting left behind
no one's getting left behind we worked
so hard to build this community of over
50 million players at this point the
last thing we would ever do is do
anything to split what an amazing
community you guys are and and how much
you mean to us so overwatch too is going
to be amazing we have a panel right here
on this stage at 1:30 where we're gonna
go into a lot more detail now it's time
for Blizzcon I'm staring you know
straight down the aisle at those
beautiful machines with Diablo 4 loaded
on them we've got World of Warcraft
Shadowlands we've got hearthstone
battlegrounds we've got two different
overwatch two demos I just want you all
to remember how much we all mean to each
other be good to each other enjoy each
other this weekend now let's go play
some video games have fun everybody
[Applause]